[Music]
welcome back to the new year's show for
people who hate new year's on to more of
the gutties next up a best hoax is it
jesse smilet or russian collusion it's a
tough call
jesse wanted to be here tonight but he
was tied up
not very tightly though
[Laughter]
what do you guys think cats hoax of the
year definitely jessie because it's been
several years that it's been going on
and it's still going on yeah he's still
saying he didn't do it yeah especially
when there's video evidence of you
rehearsing a hoax you're like you got me
not this guy
he's appealing it i mean that this is
like the biggest effort put towards a
hoax right i believe so he's he's living
the dream oaks
tyrus
watch it gut filled
um
listen uh maybe you guys don't know
about actors but most actors don't get
out of character until the dvd release
comes out
so he won't break character until the
netflix documentary comes out then he'll
be like all right guys i'm sorry i was
like the balloon boy yeah i was in
character i i i'm sorry i shouldn't have
done that is that your choice yeah it
has to be yeah yeah yeah that's good all
right dana i'm so i'm i love the
smallest story it's one of the best of
the year but i do think the 1619 project
that the new york times put forward
because it's so pervasive and it keeps
going and they win awards and prizes and
historians are literally knocking it
down
every week and they still keep going so
i would pick that one what about you
jamie the smaller one is so it's so huge
but um and you know it was a hoax dude i
saw in the video the one guy was yelling
at me was like line
i'm gonna go with the biggest hoax
though i'm going a different way i'm
gonna go uh that we put this super old
guy and pretend that he's the president
i can't believe
either
whoever did this either does not care
about our country or is extremely
committed to a bit yes
like they're really he's you know what i
think our president's andy kaufman
[Laughter]
i don't know you know okay so i'm gonna
do my hoax is kind of cause like all of
these were good i'm gonna and also i was
my choice was the reigns were whips
but i'm gonna do with there is no x
meaning when you see something with your
own eyes there was no crt in schools but
then you they show it or there was no
police defunding and they show it right
so that whenever they you say you see
there was no crime wave didn't they
would you show it so if there was no x
is my hope inflation inflation exactly
peaceful protest peaceful protest no
riots that's the hoax maybe that's a
book i think i just did a book outline
next up is the crime of the year there
were a lot to choose from is it the
smash and grab the attacks on elderly on
our city streets the bachelor host chris
harrison getting booted
me not nominated for an emmy
what do you guys think uh
dana what's the crime of the year
well
i mean it goes back to justice mollet
you know he has a bit well i can't say
that because we don't know if he's been
sentenced yet no he has he gets
sentenced in i believe january oh there
you go january yes so i was i mean i
think that was crime of the year i mean
there were some other some pretty um
stupid crimes yeah like do you guys
remember in the um convenience store you
had the guy just sitting there talking
to his friend yeah and then
these goons come in they're gonna try to
rob him and he just like takes it off oh
yeah yeah like so that wasn't they were
like an attempted crime i was saying
like those are really good oh yeah
especially when they're dude when
they're on tape what tyrus what's the
crime of the year
wow there's a lot of them
there's a lot of crimes this year yeah
there are maybe
it's just a big day for cnn i mean
they're just killing it
they they just they reported on
everything that wasn't true
and
made the
fake stories real crimes and the real
crimes didn't get reported so that's
gotta be a crime at least you uh you did
see my notes i wrote denial of crime by
cnn
wow
hey i'd like to change my
the racist is gut-felt
he just said that i wasn't smart enough
to come i had to look at his notes what
are you a liberal
cats crime of the year no the crime of
the year we don't know about because it
was such a good crime that they didn't
get caught yeah that's fair oh there you
go you know what you're talking about
the rapid testing crime where's our
rapid testing there's something going on
there and we don't know we should have
had rapid rapid testing like that
rapidly
here's another fun one biggest career
implosion it could be ellen degeneres
who was outed as a monster by her own
employees turns out her slogan be kind
meant be kind
she got so much bad press she wanted to
go back into the closet
implosion jamie biggest implosion i'm
going to go with a weird one here i
guess this is more of a life implosion
so maybe i'm wrong but i'm going to go
alex rodriguez
oh that's good because i feel like we
all like he just had like this this aura
of being like this great dude the hero
and then like the cheating on j lo and
stuff and i i get it man like um do you
know how hard it is to hit him to hit a
90 mile an hour fastball and not cheat
on your wife
pretty
hard pretty hard it's almost impossible
[Laughter]
many have tried i think i just bruised
myself
i'm like a rotten apple
tyrus biggest implosion
i mean cnn is just killing it
yeah he was he was coming on other
people's show just say hi yeah because
they couldn't wait for his show to start
like donald would be like hi it's me
like he was everybody's buddy love you
man gotcha he was you know
boy it was like basically it was cuomo's
cuomo's cuomo's everywhere cat no i got
i got one oh good good good chrissy
teigen
[Applause]
because you remember you you couldn't
like go five minutes without being like
chrissy teigen
like every hadley she was involved in
everything and now she we all forgot she
existed i mean that was really
really really really yeah she was a
super bully everywhere and then uh she
couldn't get the forgiveness that she
wanted because everybody remembered it
dana what is your i'm going to go with
smollett again because
he
could have he could have pled guilty
your code said okay right you guys i did
it and get out instead he's just you
know i mean triple down quadruple down
and he's still going yeah he's still
good he doesn't even know his career has
imploded yeah and tonight thanks to dana
perino he's going to get all his awards
so can we send him the trophies
and i also don't like how we try to take
down other people with that like destroy
those brothers yeah that's true that's
true hey greg you know how um tyrus was
like looking at your notes yeah i saw
tyrus's nose before there was just 10
pages and they all said cnn
so i would like to go back and change my
racist guy again
i was going to say cuomo but i guess not
i guess i'll just say brian williams
because we crushed him in the ratings
and he had to retire
i'm not dancing on his grave
i'm not that cheap but i
yes i am you would never
all right last one underrated story of
the year
hmm what do you say well i would say the
actually the gutfeld show beating all
the late night shows
underrated story underrated story
uh
well that's a nice sound yeah i don't
know like
i feel like there's too many stories i
think too many stories i think too many
stories too much attention on stories
everybody needs to go home and i'll give
you one you know it's an underrated
story that i had here sarah silverman
calling out joy reid and getting eaten
alive by the left i think she red-pilled
herself but anyway dana i'm gonna say
the election results of 2021 in virginia
and new jersey because the democrats
quietly started to realize when they
started looking through all the data
that people were voting against them
because of school shutdowns and other
well in the
economy but in particular it was very
much about the mask mandates and the
school shutdowns and not being able to
open businesses remember big box stores
like home depot could be open right your
small business couldn't and the
democrats who are smart are saying oh my
gosh this is coming and so 2022 is going
to be a great year for republicans
everywhere and they just keep doing more
of this thing you see it happening all
across the country uh because of omicron
democratic politicians saying okay we're
like immediately overreacting and they
don't realize just how bad that's going
to be for them next november jamie i
think the most underrated story of the
year is the seth meyers show i took
underrated literally
[Laughter]
that you did
tyrus
i mean
the crime in this country and the
defunding of the police only one network
really covered it everything else was
like nothing to see here so um yeah the
real stories that affected this country
got no air time that is a great point
all right coming up our guests pick
their favorite stories of the year